the division has undergone several
transformations since it first launched
back in March but the core shoot and
loot setup remains an exhausting time
sync that's both aggravating and
exhilarating whether you're still
spending with its briny loot system or
surrendered to its bullet sponge enemies
months ago the games first paid
expansion Underground offers an enticing
package that includes new gear sets a
third incursion and an entirely new way
to engage the game underground
operations
according to this simple yet sound and
narrative framing the forces you fought
during the campaign have since regrouped
in New York's labyrinthine subway system
and it's up to you to flush them out the
resulting missions play like a strictly
cooperative PvE version of the more PvP
focused dark zone though underground
operations function more like a new mode
than a new area operations take place
away from the open-world setting in
randomized dungeons allowing for
discrete repeatable missions with
adjustable difficulty and gameplay
variables
despite being randomized levels end up
looking just as detailed as the desolate
city above with creepy lighting and
believable destruction throughout areas
seem to fit together naturally - though
I encountered a few strange bottlenecks
and began to recognize certain reused
sections after several hours I was
consistently impressed with the variety
of the level layouts and although
underground tunnels are populated with
the same enemies you fought topside
they've developed some new tricks that
noticeably impact the flow of combat
namely alarms environmental traps and
jammers that disable your special
abilities jamming device effective for
even greater variety you can apply any
combination of Underground's 5
directives to any mission each one
handicaps your team in some way from
disabling the mini-map and directional
damage indicators to steadily draining
your health as you play but all of them
grants you bonus loot and XP if you're
successful it's a clever way to add an
enjoyable optional challenge and extend
underground longevity unfortunately
under ground forces you to unlock new
directives one at a time over the course
of many many hours the one upside to
those hours of padding underground
operations are probably the most
reliable source of quality loot in the
entire game every mission ends with a
boss and a loot chest both of which tend
to yield high-end weapons are better and
every time you level up you're gifted a
cache containing a random item anyone
who spent days grinding through dailies
in order to earn a high-end gun knows
exactly how exciting this is especially
since underground also adds four new
armor sets for the uninitiated equipping
two or more items from the same set
unlocks special stat bonuses in this
case those bonuses boost particular play
styles subtly but smartly encouraging
you to carve out a specific role each
set offers something unique that's worth
working towards which combined with the
addition of weapons and items with a 2/4
gear score makes the divisions loot
metagame alluring again the one annoying
drawback to Underground's generous
reward system desirable vendor items
still require Phoenix credits even
though I had a stash full of high-end
weapons I didn't have enough Phoenix
credits to buy items or blueprints since
there was still no way to sell gear for
anything besides basic currency if all
this talk of gear scores and Phoenix
credits has you confused
don't worry undergroud actually provides
a reasonable reentry
wait for lapsed players you'll be
miserable for the first couple hours as
you try to figure out how the games
changed
but if you overcome this opening hurdle
Underground's gear rewards will catch
you up quickly solo players be warned
though every underground mission is a no
respawn zone
if you die even once you're booted back
to base honestly it's not worth playing
alone like dead all beyond its random
dungeons and added gear sets underground
other major addition is the division 30
version Dragon's nest which despite some
fiery PS is the strongest of the three
this time around the usual grenade spam
is also accompanied by stealthy speedy
RC cars that explode into flames and if
you're under 200 gear score will
probably down you in one shot an agent
on your team requires pay you'll also
have to deal with four simultaneous
bosses who emerge from all four corners
of a rooftop arena all while snipers and
shotgunners consistently force you out
of coverage in a perverse way however
the extreme challenge is a good thing it
forces your squad to work together and
potentially makes all your loot hunting
pay off plus the final room which
requires you to flip switches while
avoiding entire sections of the floor as
they burst into flames is more
thoughtful creative and distinctive than
anything we've seen from an incursion
before it might be a pain but Dragon's
nest is definitely a step in the right
direction
in fact the same could be said for
underground as a whole the unnecessary
leveling system might slow the fun and
solo players may suffer but even agents
diving back in after months away can now
enjoy the new gameplay variations and
pick up and play nature of the 15 to 20
minute operations assuming they haven't
burned out entirely that is